these are the scenes at a market in
chengdu when chinese authorities imposed
a lockdown this week
many desperately grabbing what they
could before the shelves emptied out
some going to extreme lengths to stock
up
21 million people live here and on
thursday 157 of them tested positive for
covet 19. the government says just one
case would be enough to hit pause
but you can't call empire essential
services like supermarkets pharmacies
and hospitals will remain open
restaurants are only allowed to offer
takeaway and employees of those places
should get tested every day
every household can send one person with
a negative test result to do their
shopping once a day
mass testing means long lines even the
digital registration system keeps
crashing overwhelmed at the number of
daily entries
but testing has to be done for people to
be able to bring food back home to their
families
flights trains taxes and shared bikes
are still available for residents
medical workers and residents who have
an urgent need to go out must provide an
active test result taken within 24 hours
before using public transportation
shanghai and beijing know all too well
what it's like during a complete
lockdown
in may the w.h.o criticizing the plan to
achieve what beijing calls zero kovid 19
cases in such mega cities we
indicated that the approach
you know
will not be sustainable and considering
the behavior of the virus
i think a shift will be very important
the empty streets of major chinese
cities are a reminder of the links the
government is willing to go to stop the
pandemic
leah harding al jazeera